[Musik]
ich glaube das bringt viel aus der
fraktion
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video zusammen mit
hasbro habe ich heute was wirklich
spannend geplant und zwar veranstalte
ich heute bei ihr in der wohnung ein
spieleabend im spieleabend macht man ja
meistens zu hause mit der familie oder
mit freunden
wie auch immer ich habe heute zwei
freunde eingeladen und ja wir machen
einen spieleabend allerdings ist kein
standard spieler haben
ich habe mir ein bisschen was überlegt
ich habe mir ein paar spieler
herausgesucht werden ja immer tabu
bleibt cool
also es geht auf jeden fall schon mal
spannend aus alt ruppin louis das habe
ich persönlich auch noch nie gespielt
deswegen freue mich umso mehr außerdem
halte ich fest ich war gerade einkaufen
und habe ein paar drinks gekauft die ich
vorher also ein paar habe ich noch nie
gesehen zum beispiel dass hier keine
ahnung was das ist
vegan wir haben tomatensaft karottensaft
dass hier irgendwas mit alten steht
zumindest drauf und dieser zitronen
sierung ist natürlich auch extrem lecker
mal sehen was sie dazu sagen werden ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß mit dem
video
[Musik]
ich erkläre ich mal kurz die spieler wir
fangen ja andere tabu habt ihr
vielleicht ja auch schon mal in der
schule gespielt man teilt sich auf in
zwei teams und muss dann immer ein
entsprechendes wort dem anderen erklären
also man hat mindestens zwei team warten
ab wir haben als beispiel das wort
krautsalat dann muss man das dem team
partner erklären
man darf alle fünf wörter die hier
unterschied nicht benutzen und der
teampartner muss trotzdem auf das wort
kommen ist ja für die meisten von euch
wahrscheinlich nichts neues dann läuft
immer noch eine zeit ab das sollte ich
ihr erkennen trotzdem ist das sehr schön
verpackt und ich glaube wir haben ja auf
jeden fall wirklich eine menge menge
auswahl
wo bleiben die denn man kommt jetzt auch
mal ja ich habe schon alles aufgebaut
alles klar
[Musik]
das wurde aber auch zeit mein gott meine
leute wir haben hier einmal den juri
applaus bitte und wir haben auch
freundliche unterstützung möchten wir
wie auch ein kleinod los ich weiß nicht
ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich schon gesehen
ich habe ein bisschen was an grings
geholt wir spielen als heute ohne
alkohol
wir spielen das mit aber das viel
bessere absolut wieder nicht ich habe
mir gedacht wir fangen einfach mal an
mit looping louie hat dass irgend jemand
von euch schon mal gespielt das müssen
wir erst mal aufbauen
wir sehen uns dann gleich viel
[Musik]
so wir haben jetzt aufgebaut so sieht's
aus jeder zum beispiel kommt ist das
schon mal ein becher ich würde sagen wir
fangen schon mal noch lang mit karotten
sattlecker möchte dass die krawatten ich
muss jetzt nach warte jetzt sonntag
man muss verhindern dass diese chips
jeder hat richards von den looping louie
berührt werden und somit runter rollen
und ich würde sagen immer wenn ein chip
runter aber jemand muss ja schon mal ein
schluck trinken und der ganzen welt so
einfach stoppen 3 2 1 also du musst ein
stück innigkeit und marinus echsen und
nächste und das ist gesund davon hast
kriegst du gute augen deutlich würde
sagen dann machen wir ein bisschen sport
hier weiter hier mit dem zitronen war
das ist richtig schön sauer da würde ich
sogar freiwillig verlieren verhindern
das ist gesund das ist eine richtig
gesund
jetzt hörte sagt du machst das gewonnene
haben ja auch die plötzlich habe es fast
halten naja ich bin ja drei nein
[Applaus]
juli war er macht ein stopp sollte bei
ihr war auch noch einer woche auch noch
einer mehr um so also ich trinke jetzt
einen genüsslichen schluck und du extras
bitte 12 alter
das können die wachsen ist doch so
lecker ist heute eigentlich noch nur
dann wechseln wir das spiel
ich habe mir nämlich noch nettes eigenen
getränken nicht integer macht das nicht
so früh warum es mir jetzt auch schnell
das ist gesund so leute ich bin bereit
achtung aller immer feste drauf gehauen
nur was hat man gewappnet immer ganz nah
am mann
ich trete zeigen dass der opa drehung
das war schon ein bisschen weniger
machen wir hier jetzt überhaupt
ich weiß nicht ob ich ein jeder ein
stück länger ich weigere mich echt das
bett ring zu haus ist der echten getränk
das sind echt also ich glaube da sind
wirklich algen drin war seit ich für so
was auszuhalten so viel kleiner trinkt
ich bin da darf man nicht so
das ist nicht schlimm jetzt von peter
manche operation mir ja du hast es
wieder ausgesprochen so die erste runde
ist vorbei looping louie das war's wir
kommen jetzt zu bleibt cool das habe ich
selber noch nie gespielt
ich bin mal gespannt mit das stinkt alle
da kann es ja immer auch auspacken so
leute marie erklärt jetzt mal kurz die
spielregeln ok also das hier ist der
kilometer der kommt auf den kopf dann
muss man es sicher nicht sind von einem
presse damit das den puls finden kann
wenn das den platz gefunden hat dann
fängt das an hier so leicht signale
auszusenden und wir müssen würfeln also
die anderen beiden spieler wissen
würfeln
ich hätte zum beispiel machte maßen dann
müssen wir die massen untergründen
ja das ist wirklich personen die den
kilometer auf dem kopf hat außer fassung
soll ich das auch ein kompromiss
grün ist nicht mehr lustig und ich würde
sagen jetzt erst mal kurz ich zeige
ihnen wie das geht das
[Musik]
das ist oft wissen glaubt dass bringen
viele aus der fraktion
ich habe es euch gefallen lassen dann
nach oben da check auf jeden fall die
spiele ab sind alle in der videoschirmen
verlinkt vor allem das sieht man ich
echt lustig habe ich vorher noch nie
gesehen werden uns demnächst wieder ich
hoffe halt schöne weihnachten haben
schönheit ich abend haut rein weil die
aussagen dank fürs mitmachen
[Musik]